These night lights are a must if your kids are afraid of the dark.
They are perfect because they are a dimmable and motion sensor.
I got them to put in the hallway between my kids room in the bathroom.
I don't want a light that stays on all night,
but I also need a light so they're not afraid to go to the bathroom.
That's what makes these kin deep night lights so perfect.
I can set them to stay on,
I can set them to be motion sensors
and I can control the brightness.
I don't know about you,
but I don't wanna get up in the middle of the night
to go to the bathroom and be blinded by my night light.
I wanna stay half asleep so I can go back to sleep real fast.
So if you are anything like me,
grab yourself some of these night lights from the TikTok shop.